foreign
the Greek Wedding extended universe is
going into some paths I just can't
follow it down also judging by how often
my washer breaks down I can't imagine a
worse option to use is the exit slash
entrance to your secret spy elevator
their electrical machines purposely
built to fill with water and vibrate
themselves into Oblivion and that's what
you want between you and escape from a
metal tomb Nikolai how could you do this
KGB surveillance team now how you ask
why getting frustrated with someone who
uses English as a secondary language
after your semantically specific pronoun
gaming
considering where this story goes it
seems like a true waste that they blow
past activities and Krakow without even
a whiff of anyone's entender being
duplicated all Hispanics look roguish
another says something offensive because
she has no filter and no real
understanding of right and wrong in the
audience is supposed to find it funny
just because it's a terrible thing to
say cliche okay let's see here we'll
take quick screen grab zoom in a bit now
we just run it through Google translate
and I love technology it just makes
everything so much toad chicken love
candy I just saw here are the keys and
the D to my condo in South Beach and
Mallory is worried about the government
shutting down ISIS after whatever is
being leaked is leaked naturally her
solution is to immediately donate her
Miami apartment to a Cuban secret agent
along with a lump sum sure nothing
suspicious about that at all I said I
could eat the absolute pants off some
shrimp pretentious restaurants that make
you deepans your own shrimp and probably
charge you extra for the privilege also
searching for shrimp pants yielded more
relevant results than I think is good
for society also also wait they're
actually having lunch together this is
the man that's blackmailing you out of
your condo a ton of cash and putting
your entire livelihood at risk and
you're happily going on a luncheon date
with him I don't suppose he's up wait a
second was Archer serving a
non-sparkling fermented beverage in a
champagne flute I knew he was a heathen
but I didn't think he'd stoop this low
and from the looks of it it's not
mentioning the Lemur in the room by
saying you won't mention the Lemur in
the room what else we got any lube like
at this point even olive oil would
yes I researched this no it isn't a good
idea yes I regret my choices no I
wouldn't change a thing Jesus God
lings
those are just just costumes and I
suppose that makes it better doesn't it
Sterling would be excellent at barely
keeping himself out of jail since now I
know you're familiar with the honey pot
seducing and blackmailing a hot female
enemy agent describing things everyone
participating in the conversation
already knows so that the passive
participants you shouldn't know are
watching can feel included too sure that
stolen name a big one of your
prostitutes right in the face wait
earlier Archer said a Woodhouse I told
my guests you'd pack their lunch who
packs a lunch for people you're paying
for sexual Shenanigans I don't hire a
plumber and then send them away with PB
and J wait am I supposed to am I the
here also expecting me to
believe that the sound of a sex worker
being bitten in the face by an Irate
primate wouldn't have been heard
throughout the entire apartment and most
of the city she says she can't go to
hospital because she's quote tripping
balls well then clear a path for her
Woodhouse jeez wouldn't it consider it
time to be organizing your marble
collection anyway Bang
ew kill bang shock shut up oh my god
bang why would you specify bang for one
person and kill for another how do you
differentiate between shooting someone
and just wishing them dead Jesus Krieger
you're still taping bum fights no now
I'm into something
darker nocturnal bum fights we have some
more tubs of chaos here but the one that
really burns my toast is a sorted screws
assorted are you telling me that within
this giant tub is just a mess of
different sized screws that's Insanity
nothing damages your cuticles more than
rifling through who misspelled aspirin
every movie TV show Answer to Soleil
production to take place Miami feels the
need to show a butt in one of their
establishing shots and none of them dare
to explain why the tip of America's love
spear has chosen our split ends as its
mascot I'm just putting it out there
I'll just put it back in Archer isn't
here in the scene to say phrasing
not wearing protective skating gear is
this some sort of viral marketing I'm
fairly certain if you sign up to
whatever Archer is selling you'll be
exposed to something viral you are
entirely too gay thinking it's even
possible for someone to be too happy
expecting me to believe that this is a
world where spy agencies like Odin are
fine with having their secret agents on
the front cover of whatever this
magazine is about also this is the most
unrealistic couple ever what couple buys
the same magazine twice you buy two
different magazines and then you can
switch with your partner once you're
done honestly this is the weirdest thing
in the whole episode like somebody
murdering me it's so
intimate making me even more afraid of
intimacy I want to dress you up like a
little gnome and just have you live in
my garden teasing us with the
possibility of Woodhouse having a better
life episode never explains who this guy
is nor why he's following Ramon Mallory
and or Archer everywhere with nothing
more than the addition or removal of
glasses as a disguise well I was very
fond of a boy at school once
but he died and skipped where were you
all night way the Christ out in the
Everglades burying some Dominican guy's
rooster fun
what Oh you mean literally Archer
returns equipped with a shovel a dirty
shirt and a seemingly accidental
homosexual euphemism sadly said
euphemism comes at the expense of
everything we know about Archer is he
really the type of person to spend an
entire night helping a stranger bury
their dead chicken this is the most
selfless thing we've ever seen Archer do
he should have poached that chicken
literally and figuratively what the
is with this tape dispenser is it
secretly a weapon does it shoot spikes
is it a camouflaged garotte wire is the
adhesive on the tape some kind of
fast-acting neurotoxin why is tape get
me some video of hot man on man
don't bother coming home thinking the
temperature of the men in your blackmail
video matters wait a minute how do you
know Ramon's playing highlight right now
um he's Latino so it's either that or
Domino's no that explains or they're
badly by the way how you know what he's
doing not the fact that he's doing it
right now or where he's doing it don't
you ever give up not when it comes to
somebody refusing to have sex with me
you know consensually or whatever yeah
I'm afraid it's that pesky or whatever
part that just makes it really hard to
ever want Archer to succeed and if we
don't want him to succeed why is so much
of every episode spent on him succeeding
debate apparently you can only divide
271 by one in the number itself meaning
it has exactly two factors and since it
has two factors 271 is a prime number oh
damn it I involuntarily mouthed again
you are playing a very dangerous game
Sterling Archer of Isis consciously
talking to your unconscious victim just
so the viewer knows that you know what
the viewer already knows you know also
shock he figured out that Archer is
Mallory sudden working for Isis we won't
find out how Ramon figures this out but
we honestly don't need to Isis sucks so
bad that it's incredulous that
undercover missions aren't off the table
entirely you found Krieger's cameras
thinking these big ass cameras could be
hidden in the first place so are you two
even really gay as big old tangerines
yes confusing me about the size and
sexual orientation of a piece of produce
then how can you work for Castro you
know he stands on homosexuality equally
baffling is why Castro hired these two
in the first place if he's so against
the existence of homosexuals let's
Outsource it to some cracked up Haitians
that's what I said Outsourcing murder or
just the concept of sourcing in general
as it applies to people really anything
that allows someone to refer to a person
by a three-letter acronym NOW if I've
lost you on that one don't look it up
just hold on to your innocence and if
you see what's on these discs
you weren't gay you will be oh what
what if Mother assuming that viewing of
maternal sex tape would make you gay now
I'm not saying it isn't possibly going
to do some serious emotional damage but
chucking that into the same bucket as
homosexuality might be a step too far
Archer and that's in the same episode
where we have Cheryl getting aroused by
the thought of a drooling fireman
strangling her to death I bet you're not
even a real interior decorator well he's
not licensed or anything making me so
curious that I had to dive into the
murky Waters of bureaucratic red tape
just so I could find out that no U.S
state requires a license to work as an
interior decorator sure there are
exceptions but I assure you they aren't
interesting enough for the amount of
time I spent on that where's Charles and
Rudy hmm I think they must have escaped
however implausible that may seem that
does seem implausible you can
acknowledge an implausibility as much as
you like but is still
but one of the financial Arrangements
lines up straight like that right to the
right of it and to the left of it are
Pockets right in those pockets of money
look in either one of them pay the bill
what else we got any lube for the record
those are hand towels the big towels are
on the top shelf what is the melody
you've committed
[Music]
wait did Cyril play this stupid game
love games I want to dress you up like a
little gnome and just have you live in
my garden know your limits most away the
citric acid from the limes actually
Cooks the fish try it
um
that is sort of an Oaky after birth